hi Matt here I wanted to invite you to
check out our latest newsletter at
faster
smarter. this newsletter covers meetings
how to run them better and be better in
meetings also at faster smarter. you can
subscribe to the newsletter see old
editions find quick tip videos along
with our new English language learning
material finally there's information
about my new book think faster talk
smarter so check out faster smarter.
today loved it hated it that
sucked feedback is critical to improving
our communication skills but how do we
do it right so it's meaningful I'm Matt
Abrahams I teach strategic communication
at Stanford Graduate School of Business
and welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today I'm really excited to speak with
Kim Scott Kim is an executive an author
and a speaker she wrote The New York
Times bestseller radical cander be a
kick-ass boss without losing your
humanity and just work how to root out
bias Prejudice and bullying to create a
kick-ass culture of
inclusivity Kim also held important
senior leadership and development roles
at Google and apple and she's also an
executive coach welcome Kim I'm super
excited to talk to you and and our
former guest and friend Bob Sutton
speaks super highly of your work shall
we jump in let's do it thanks so much
for having me awesome to begin can you
share your definition of radical cander
sure radical cander is just caring
personally and challenging directly at
the same time and that caring and
challenging don't sound so radical so
why why do I call them radical they're
radical because they're rare and as an
explanation of why they're rare I want
to explain what happens when we fail on
one dimension or another so in order to
do this I'm I I love a good visual so
I'm going to draw in words a 2 by two
framework on the vertical axis is care
personally on the horizontal axis is
challenge directly so when you do both
in the upper right hand quadrant that's
radical cander when you challenge
directly but you fail to show that you
care personally that is obnoxious
aggression and obnoxious aggression is a
big problem it's problem because it
hurts other people it's a problem
because it's a waste of breath if I am
obnoxious to you if I'm a jerk to you
you go into fight ORF flight mode and
then you can't hear what I'm saying but
it's also a problem because I don't know
about you but for me at least when I
realize I've acted like a jerk when I
realize I've landed in the obnoxious
aggression quadrant it is not my
instinct to go the right way on the care
personally Dimension instead it's my
instinct to go the wrong way on
challenge directly and then I wind up in
the dreaded bottom leftand quadrant in
the worst place of all manipulative
insincerity if obnoxious aggression is
front stabbing manipulative insincerity
is backstabbing it's where manipulative
insincerity is where back is where
political Behavior it's where you know
all of the worst passive aggressive
behavior all of the worst kinds of
behavior creep in and it's also where
there's a lot of drama there's drama in
obnoxious aggression there's drama in
manipulative insincerity if you watch
the office you're going to see a lot of
episodes about both of those things but
it's not where the most mistakes get
made it's just where the drama is the
vast majority of us make the vast
majority of our mistakes when we do
remember to show We Care personally so
we're now in the upper leftand quadrant
because we're failing to challenge
directly so we're caring but we're not
challenging that I call ruinous empathy
and that is what happens when we don't
tell someone something they'd be better
off knowing in the long run because we
don't want to hurt their feelings that
is perhaps the best definition of a
concept we've had on this this podcast
it's very clear to me and I am curious
to learn where that came from because I
think it had to do with filler words I
learned about all this shortly after I
moved to California to take a job at
Google and I had to give a presentation
about how the AdSense business was doing
to the founders and the CEO and I walked
into the room and there in one corner of
the room was one of the founders on an
elliptical trainer you know wearing
bright blue to
shoes stepping away and also wearing a
bright blue matching super
tight spandex unitard not what I was
expecting or frankly wanting to see in
the room you know and there in the other
corner of the room was the CEO doing his
emails like his brain had been plugged
into the machine so probably like all of
your listeners in such a situation I
felt a little bit nervous how was I
supposed to get these people's attention
luckily for me the AdSense business was
on fire and when I said how many new
customers we had added over the last
couple of weeks the CEO almost fell off
his chair what did you say this is
incredible do you need more marketing
dollars do you need more Engineers so
I'm thinking that the meeting is going
all right yeah in fact I now believe
that I am a
genius and I walked out of the room when
the meeting was over I walked past my
boss and I'm expecting a high five a pat
on the back and instead she says to me
why don't you walk back to my office
with me and I thought oh wow I screwed
something up I'm sure I'm about to hear
about it and I wasn't totally dreading
hearing about it because she had already
multiple times solicited feedback from
me and seemed to really appreciate it so
I knew that she kind of thought of
feedback as a gift but of course that
didn't help that much I was still
nervous so we started off walking and
she starts by telling me about the
things that had gone well not the things
that had gone badly but of course not
and not really in the in the feedback
sandwich but really seeming to mean what
she said but of course all I wanted to
know was what I had done wrong
eventually she said to me you said I'm a
lot in there were you aware of it and
with this I breathed a huge sigh of
relief cuz if that was all I had done
wrong who cared you know and I kind of
made a brush off gesture with my hand
and she looked at me again and she said
said you know I know this great speech
coach I bet Google would pay for it
would you like an introduction and once
again I made this brush off gesture with
my hand I said I know I'm busy I don't
have time for a speech coach didn't you
hear about all those new customers and
then she stopped she looked me right in
the eye and she said I can tell when you
do that thing with your hand that I'm
going to have to be a lot more direct
with
you when you say um every third word it
makes you sound stupid now she's got my
full attention and some people might say
it was mean of her to say that I sounded
stupid but in fact it was the kindest
thing she could have done for me at that
moment in my career CU if she hadn't
used just those words with me and by the
way this is a really important Point she
never would have used those words with
other people on her team who are perhaps
a better listener than I was right but
with me she knew me well enough to know
that if she didn't use just those words
I never would have gone to see the
speech coach and I wouldn't have learned
that she was not exaggerating I
literally said um every third word and
this was a big shock to me because I had
been giving presentations my whole
career I had raised millions of dollars
for two different startups giving
presentations I thought I was pretty
good at it right this almost got me to
thinking it was almost like I had gone
through my whole career with a giant
hung of spinach between my teeth and
nobody had had the common courtesy to
tell me it was there and it got me to
thinking why had no one told me but also
what was it about my boss and her
leadership style that made it so
seemingly easy for her to tell me and as
I thought about her leadership style I
realized it boiled down to these two
very simple things care personally and
challenge directly how did I know that
she cared about me not just as an
employee but as a human being when I
moved from New York to California to
take the job I was really lonely because
I didn't know anyone out here and she
could tell that I was lonely she
introduced me to a book group and I'm
still friends with a bunch of those
people to this day I when about couple
of months after I took the job at at
Google my father was diagnosed with with
late stage cancer and I was devastated
and she knew I was
devastated and she said Kim you need to
get on a plane fly home to Memphis you
need to be with your family right now
your team and I will sit down and write
your coverage plan that's what teams do
for one another they they we've got your
back
and those were the kinds of things she
didn't do just for me she did for
everyone who worked closely with her but
of course she couldn't do th those kind
of things for all 5,000 people in her
organization no matter how talented a
leadership a leader is sort of
relationships don't scale right but
culture does scale when a leader treats
their direct reports with that kind of
care it's much much more likely in turn
that their direct reports are going to
treat their direct reports with that
kind of care and that does create a
culture of caring but of course it
wasn't all sunshine and Roses I also
knew beyond the shadow of a doubt that
if I messed up she was going to tell me
in no uncertain terms so that I could
fix it and that really was all there was
to it absolutely so I love that you had
a direct experience it was sort of your
Epiphany to look into that and and I
have to comment and compliment you no
ums and O in that entire story so I'm
curious to get very tactical in how you
give the feedback you referred to the
feedback sandwich where you say
something positive then the then the
real Crux to the feedback and then you
say something positive what's the
structure or advice you give in radical
cander for giving feedback yeah I think
the first thing to remember is you
should never start by giving it you
should start by soliciting it like
there's a real order of operations to
radical cander and that's not to say
this is like some kind of Six Sigma
process this is something you can do in
one conversation it's fast it's free all
it takes is enormous emotional
discipline that's what's in short supply
I think right but remember that you
don't want to dish it out before you
prove you can take it you always want to
start by soliciting it okay and then you
want to give it but one of the mistakes
I think that I've made in the way I talk
about I'll be self radically candid for
a moment is that all I've I often leave
people with the sense that radical
cander is all about the boss criticizing
the employee and it's not it should
always start with soliciting and then
the next step is to give praise not
criticism again not in the feedback
sandwich sense of the word but in the
Gratitude sense of the word in the
generosity sense of the word you want to
make sure that you're taking a beat to
give voice to the things you appreciate
about working with this person and not
one beat but a Beat you know on a daily
basis a daily beat you want to focus on
the good stuff and then when it comes
time to offer the criticism so if now
you've solicited it you've given voice
to what you appreciate and this can
happen in one conversations or multiple
but once you've done that now it's now
now you've you've kind of gotten
yourself into the right frame of mind to
to give
criticism that is helpful you know you
want to State your intention to be
helpful you want to make sure that
you're being humble you could be wrong
omniscience is not a requirement for
radical cander thank goodness right you
could be wrong and that's okay you you
the reason why I call it cander and not
truth is that to me cander kind of
implies a dialogue it's here's how I
understand the situation I also am
curious to know how you understand the
situation we're going to talk about it
and then you want you want to
offer both praise and criticism sort of
immediately M if the purpose of praise
is to tell a person what to do more of
the purpose of criticism is to tell them
what to do less of why wait right it
doesn't do any good and also I find in
in the case of criticism if you wait it
kind of piles up it pile you know we're
in Silicon Valley people talk a lot
about technical debt here I think
sometimes we have feedback debt and and
feedback debt what happens is it winds
up exploding kind of in unpredictable
ways in the before times I used to say
had these conversations in person now
that's often impossible but I think you
want to have these conversations
synchronously MH you don't want to send
a text slack is a feedback train wreck
waiting waiting to happen because slack
is is often like public criticism in
writing asynchronous like it's it it
hits all the wrong notes so you want to
make sure that you're having a
conversation with a person and there's
increasingly there's evidence that it's
better to pick up the phone and just
have a voice conversation and not do a
video conversation right you also want
to make sure that you're praising in
public criticizing and private and that
you're not giving
somebody praise or criticism about their
personality MH right instead you want
you want to focus on having a growth
mindset giving people praise and
criticism about things that they can
either do more of or do less of so the
best way I know of to do that is to
think about your praise and your
criticism in terms of context
observation result next steps so in the
meeting when you said um every third
word it made you sound stupid go visit
the speech coach or in the meeting when
you offered both sides of the argument
it earned you credibility do more of
that so that's those are some thoughts
now but you're not done next step so you
had you solicited it you gave Praise You
Gave criticism now you got to gauge how
it lands because again it's a dialogue
not a monologue although I feel like I'm
giving a monologue right now we're doing
a great job we're learning a lot I'm
learning at time yeah
so there's a process yes and within the
process there's a structure you start by
soliciting feedback asking for feedback
about yourself MH praise is to be given
often yes and I assume you would agree
congruent with the level of criticism
that you're giving you don't say oh you
look very nice today and by the way
you're lousy at this job that's problem
with the feedback sandwich is oh Kim I
like your glasses your book was terrible
but those are nice shoes like it's not
really going to make me feel better so
you give the praise and then the part
that I really liked that when you talked
about cander cander is not the truth it
is a perspective and it sounds what I
what I so appreciate about your model
there many things is this notion of it's
it's an invitation for dialogue to
discuss yeah and that's where I think
that cander is really important and then
you have a structure for how you give
both praise as well as the constructive
criticism and and then you have to check
for how it lands and I think that's very
useful and and it can be very helpful to
have a process to not only because it
helps get you from A to B but it helps
you think about what needs to be said
and that's really important you
mentioned emotions and an emotional
deficit yes emotion often looms large
especially in constructive criticism
what advice and guidance do you have for
handling our emotions like you've done
something that frustrates me and I I I
want to share that but I know that can
get in the way or I don't want to evoke
emotions that are negative in you
because I think that'll get in the way
how do we deal with emotions I think one
of the things that has been really
helpful to me is to think about when we
communicate we communicate on an
emotional plane and a rational plane at
the same time and very often we tend to
try to pretend like the emotional plane
is
somehow not fair game especially at work
and the problem is if you ignore the
emotional signals that your own body is
sending you or that the other person is
sending you then you're just not going
to communicate very well so I think part
of it is to remember that that emotion
has to be a part of this equation I if
you try to show up at work like some
kind of robot you're never going to go
very high on the care personally
Dimension you know very often if the
other person is sad or mad that is your
cue to go up on the care personally
Dimension but if you're like me it's
probably not your instinct if the other
person seems sad it is so tempting for
me to zoom over to ruin a sympathy and
to say ah you know it's okay it's no big
deal it doesn't really matter but it's
not okay and it is a big deal and it
does really matter that's why I just
said it you know and so if I do that
then I leave the person both sad and
confused and that's not Kinder right
right so the the the right thing to do
in in the face of someone else's upset
is is to try to pause for a moment and
to say you know I don't think I said
that very well how might I have said it
better to maybe back up and start
soliciting some feedback but what do you
do if the other person is not sad but
they're mad maybe they start yelling at
you you know it's pretty hard to care
personally about someone who is yelling
at you right if you're like me It's Your
Instinct either to start yelling back
and wind up in obnoxious aggression or
to creep over to a kind of
self-protective manipulative insincerity
right right and that's that's normal it
doesn't mean you're a lesser mortal or
incapable of feedback it just means
you're human and so first of all you
know extend some Grace to yourself but
then try to move up on the care
personally Dimension and one of the
things that I try to tell myself in
those moments is when Furious get
curious oh I like that someone's mad I'm
getting mad back I I try to take a deep
breath try if I have a bottle of water
I'll unscrew the top take a sip of water
and I try
to figure out like what is what has gone
wrong here like why is this person so
upset and don't blame yourself one of
the things that often happens I'll be
coaching someone and helping them
prepare for a conversation that they're
kind of dreading and they'll call me up
and they say uh you know I totally
messed that one up either the the person
started crying or the person started
yelling and that doesn't mean the fact
that the other person got emotional does
not necessarily mean that you messed up
it means that they're having an emotion
and your job is not to control that
emotion your job is to remain present
for that emotion and to remain caring
about that person for that emotion now
there's another thing that could happen
other than the person gets sad or mad
other times and remember it is your job
to go North to to choose the right
Vector on the radical caner 2 by two and
to move up on care personally but that's
not the only emotional response that the
person may have the person may do to you
what I did to my boss in the um story
they may brush you off right and when
that happens it's your job to keep going
out on the challenge directly
Dimension probably more further mhm
you're probably further than you're
comfortable going sure right and that is
hard for a lot of us in fact when I was
when I was writing radical caner I sent
that story to my boss and she said gosh
did I really say you sounded stupid I'm
so sorry that sounds so mean you know so
even she wasn't that comfortable with it
clear as kind as B Brown says the
kindest thing she could have done for me
is to keep going on that on that
challenge directly Dimension and she as
you notice she tried three times right
and that is often true that you have to
try more than once and and often it
takes more than one conversation to get
through to someone and that doesn't mean
they're shut down to feedback
necessarily it just means communication
is really hard right so many Rich ideas
in there when it comes to emotion I
heard you say and I rightly believe this
that it's normal and natural we have to
honor it we don't try to hide it or or
over project it we need to take time
to reflect in the in the flare up of an
emotion that I personally feel I'm sure
others feel the same way when things get
heated I want to adjust and and I'm
agitated in that moment and it sounds
like being present stepping back I love
your when people get furious get curious
so so really introspect but also ask but
but not only when the other person is
furious when you yourself are Furious
cuz cuz if if you get mad at me and
start yelling I'm probably going to get
mad back like anger is very reflective
one of the challenges many people have
in part of that process you talked about
is actually asking for feedback it can
be hard yeah and when it comes to
soliciting feedback from others we've
had two different guests bring this up
on their own I didn't initiate it Bob
chalini and Jonah Burger both talked
about research that that looks at how
you ask for feedback the literally the
words you use matters and I know that
something that's important for you is
that you ask for guidance you don't
actually use the word feedback as much
can you share a little bit about how we
can best ask for that feedback yes
because if you say do you have any
feedback for me you are wasting your
breath I can already tell you the answer
oh no everything's fine unless you have
teenage children nobody in your life
wants to give you feedback your teenage
kids are delighted to provide the
service for you if everyone actually
listening can can if unless you're
driving don't do this if you're driving
but but if you have a pen and paper
handy write down what your question is
and there's a few elements to a good
question one is it it's got to sound
like you not like me so I'll tell you my
question but don't write my question
down because if you sound like Kim Scott
people won't believe you want to know
the answer so the question I like to ask
is what could I do or stop doing that
would make it easier to work with me and
the reason why I like that question is
it's pretty open it it allows there
there may be things I'm not aware of
that the person wants to tell me that I
haven't created a space for them to tell
me the other important thing about that
question is that it can't be answered
with a yes or a no right right it's not
enough when you're soliciting feedback
actually to
have a good question because no matter
how good your question is the other
person still is not going to want to
answer
it so the next step there's four steps I
think to soliciting feedback The Next
Step is really to make sure that you're
embracing the discomfort mhm that you
sort of close your mouth and count to
[Music]
six we I only made it to three just
there neither one of us could stand it
anymore could that's right so so 6
seconds is a really long time the other
person will probably tell you something
if you can manage to remain silent for
six seconds and when they say whatever
it is that they say the next most
important thing is to make sure that
you're listening with the intent to
understand not to respond because even
though you just solicited feedback when
you get it you're probably going to feel
a little bit defensive It Might Sting a
little bit and the fact that you feel
defensive does not mean you're a lesser
mortal or that you're shut down the
feedback it means you're human and
that's okay that's all part of this so
what you want to do is try to ask a
couple of follow-up questions so for
example my daughter said to me at
breakfast one morning Mom I wish you
were not the radical cander lady and
immediately this wave of Parental guilt
washed over me I thought I knew what the
feedback was I thought she was telling
me I was spending too much time at work
she wanted more time with me but then I
thought well I should I should make sure
I understand so I said well who do you
wish I were and she said I wish you were
the lady who minded her own business so
totally different kind of so you want to
make sure you're asking follow questions
that you really again getting curious
you can also get curious when you feel
defensive it's great emotion to try to
find your way too right and then last
but not least you got to reward the
cander so four steps you you you had to
come up with your question you had to
embrace the discomfort you had to listen
with the intent not not to respond but
to understand and last but not least you
got to reward the cander because when
someone offers you some radical cander
they are taking an interpersonal risk
right and as with money with
interpersonal risk we expect a high
reward and if we don't get a high reward
we're not going to do it again right and
so you got to make sure if you agree
with the feedback that you fix the
problem and if you disagree with the
feedback that you are radically candid I
mean first of all look for that five or
10% of what they said that you can agree
with just to show that you were
listening right and to make sure that
you're proving that you're not shut down
the feedback and then tell ask for the
rest of it I want to thank about if
you're feeling defensive I want to think
about it and get back to you if you're
not feeling defensive I want to explain
to you why I disagree but thank you for
telling me and let's try to get onto the
same page you can't argue endlessly at
some point you got to listen challenge
commit but if you just tell the person
whose feedback you disagreed with thank
you for the feedback you know what they
hear is a giant Fu so so make sure that
you tell that you're radically candid
about the radical
cander that that reflexiveness is yeah
that meta is important though you talked
about risk and there is a lot of risk in
giving radically candid feedback how as
Leaders as managers do we set up a
culture and an environment that supports
and rewards that kind of feedback I I'm
sure modeling it is important but what
else do you do I think one of the things
you can do is is to remind yourself that
your number number one priority as a
leader is to solicit feedback and to
make it to reward speaking truth to
power not to punish speaking truth to
power and this is this is hard because
very often when people think about
leadership and radical caner they assume
boss criticizing employee and that's
again not where it should start it
should always start with boss soliciting
feedback so go back to that order of
operations there's a couple of things
you can do to make this sort of normal
one is you can prevent backstabbing you
want you want to create a norm on your
team of what Fred Kaufman calls clean
escalation and so clean escalation is
basically just means don't talk badly
about someone behind their back right
it's not this is not a complicated idea
and yet so often if you're frustrated
with someone on your team it's tempting
to go to your boss and talk to them and
it's tempting as the boss to listen
because you feel like you're being the
empathetic leader this is the one time
when listening is counterproductive as a
leader because if you listen all you're
doing is stirring the political pot
right you want to say to that person go
talk you know if if you have James
talking badly about Jane you want to say
James go talk to Jane directly and
there's acceptions of course like if
it's a sexual harassment thing don't do
that but if it's in the normal kind of
conversation you want to encourage
people to talk to each other directly
and then if they can't work it out you
want to offer them your conflict
resolution services in other words ask
them to come talk to you together
together right you are not a shuttle
Diplomat as a manager you're more like a
marriage counselor and that means you
can't talk to one person about another
person who's not in the room this has
been wonderful Kim I really appreciate
your Insight and your feedback before we
end I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I ask everybody all right here
we go question number one if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you've ever received as a five to
seven-word presentation slide title what
would it be the words I don't know okay
and the power of those words tell us so
the reason why I don't know is so
important is that very found
foundational to all of this is is to be
humble and the whole goal of radical
caner is to learn MH and to learn what
we don't know and to help other people
learn what they don't know and so being
willing to say I don't know it earns it
it just takes all of the tension out of
the room sometimes it's it's something
that we don't say nearly often enough it
it feels very risky and it feels you
make yourself vulnerable but in that is
a ton of possibility and and it also can
level power and status and I think
that's really important question number
two who's a communicator you admire and
why so I love novels okay to me a novel
teaches us empathy really and compassion
not ruinous empathy but productive
empathy and and compassion and I think
that Tony Morrison is probably the
communicator I admire most most deeply I
was lucky enough to take a course with
her in college oh wow and I learned so
much about language and how to use
language for good not for evil it's
funny as soon as you mentioned Tony I I
thought of language and you're
absolutely right question number three
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe there's only two all right caring
and challenging very good and not
surprising at all coming coming from you
I had one extra in there just in case
Kim this has been fantastic thank you I
will give you praise th this was very
helpful to to really put feedback in its
proper place as a critical skill the
specific process and steps are very
helpful and really allowing us and
giving us permission to open ourselves
up to receive the feedback and do so in
a way that that can set examples for
others thank you for your time and thank
you for your input thank you and can I
end by walking the talk and soliciting a
little criticism sure because it I want
some radical caner on radical caner
because it's so easy to say be radically
candid really hard to do it what do you
think is the one thing that gets in the
way that we didn't talk about today why
don't people do this more
often I think people are really worried
about their relative status yes in the
in the relationship that they have and
that this is going to risk their
position status and connection they have
with people and it can be very scary in
around this place as a as a teacher and
in this Valley there are so many
Dynamics going on and everybody knows
everybody in some way you're afraid not
only for the interaction I have with you
but what it might mean in the larger
Network all right so let's figure out
how to take status and power out of the
equation to make it safe absolutely and
nice paraphrasing all right very good
thank you you've been listening to
another episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast a production of Stanford
Graduate School of Business this podcast
was produced by Jenny Luna Kevin Patel
and me Matt Abrahams with special thanks
to Podium podcast company to find more
episodes visit our website at gb.
stanford.edu or find us wherever you get
your podcasts including YouTube for more
business related content follow the
business school on social media at
Stamford GSB you can also find the
podcast and follow us on LinkedIn and
Instagram